it's official Mark Ballas is engaged
the Dancing with the Stars Pro and
longtime girlfriend BC Jean shared the
big news on Instagram and get this
they've been engaged for months
Marc revealed he popped the question
just after Thanksgiving writing it was
the best day of my life and it couldn't
have been more perfect we kept it on the
quiet for a while as we just wanted to
soak it in over the holidays in the
lengthy caption the 29 year old also
gave this adorable shout-out to his
bride-to-be knowing that I am going to
spend the rest of my days with BC gives
me more comfort than anything else ever
could
she's the best thing that has ever
happened to me and I can't wait for our
life ahead BC returned the sentiment on
her instead writing I can't wait to
marry the king of my heart and best
friend and continue our journey of
forever with love music and adventures
mark is just the latest Dancing with the
Stars Pro to get engaged Maksim
Chmerkovskiy asked Peeta Murgatroyd for
her hand in marriage in December while
julianne hough got engaged to hockey
player Brooks Laich in August